المزيد من الانفجارات في وحول أه مفتاح
العاصمة الأوكرانية الليلة حيث
دخلت حرب فلاديمير بوتين ضد البلاد اليوم الثالث.
cnn alex marquardt
هو في العاصمة آه مفتاح بالنسبة لنا آه
أليكس لذا أخبر مشاهدينا بما
تراه أه ما تسمعه الآن
ما كان يحدث خلال
الدقائق العديدة الماضية
الذئب الجيد ما هو مذهل حقًا هو
أنه مذهل بشكل لا يصدق  الهدوء في المدينة
حتى يخترق هذا الصمت
أصوات القتال ، سمعنا
بعض الانفجارات الأقرب إلى
وسط مدينة كييف في الساعة الماضية
فقط إلى الجزء الغربي من المدينة على
بعد بضعة أميال أو كيلومترات فقط  بعيدا
أه هذا هو الذي هو
أقرب الانفجارات أقرب علامات
القتال أه كما يتطلع الروس
لتطويق المدينة التي رأيناها الآن
ورائي مباشرة إلى الشرق
كما تردنا تقارير عن المزيد من الضراوة.
تقاتل ، ثم مرة أخرى إلى
الجنوب والآن يقترن ذلك بما
نعرفه أن الروس
يقومون بدفعهم الرئيسي
قادمًا من الشمال ، لذا يتم تطويق هذه المدينة
تدريجيًا